Rita, Justin, congratulations.
You guys have made
it to the final round
of this competition.
Now it's time to send you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the sodegarami.
Holy!
Geez!
Oh my god!
1, 2, 3.
Today, we are protesting
the sodegarami.
I've tested long shafted
weapons before but nothing
with this many spikes.
This weapon has
spikes everywhere.
It's got spikes on the shaft,
all around, facing outwards.
It's got hooks, and points,
and spikes facing at you.
This weapon is spike-tacular.
I'm so excited to
use the sodegarami.
One of the most intimidating
and versatile Japanese pole
weapons, the sodegarami was part
of the key arsenal for samurai
police during the 17th century.
Featuring lethal
spikes and hooks,
police were able to
capture violent offenders
from a distance by
using the weapon
to latch onto the suspects,
stopping them in their tracks.
Although primarily
used in defense,
the sharp spikes, along
with the spiked bud cap,
made it a menacing and
brutal weapon when in combat.
Today, the sodegarami's
devastating use
can be seen in the HBO
television series "Westworld."
It's got spikes everywhere
because it's supposed
to be a sleeve catcher--
something that when you
wield it and hit something, it's
supposed to catch on something.
You bring it down, and
you spike him with it.
MAN: Action.
That is why we have
these pre-tests--
so that we find out
how to best bring
out the effectiveness of this
weapon according to its design.
So, we use ballistics
dummies because it gives us
the anatomy of the human body.
Feel of boom-- oh, that
penetrates deep into the guts.
You're not going
to survive that.
When you're cutting
into the skin,
oh, that's just not a cut.
That actually crushed the
bones and into the heart.
So it's a very visual
thing to find out
what kind of lethal
damage that weapon can
really do to the human body.
My hand placement is
important because there
are spikes in areas that
if I put my hand there
to make it lighter be
able to maneuver it,
I'm going to get spiked.
How do you use this thing?
And obviously, any way you want.
[chatter]
Have fun!
It's yours.
Leave.
All right.
It looks like it's
going to be fun to make.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
My name is Rita Thurman.
I just turned 50 years old.
I'm a scout leader, and
it's important for me
to be here and be an example for
my scouts and for my daughter
because I want them to try
things, even if it's hard.
I have never made
anything like this before.
I am going to start
with my entangler.
Super awesome.
It's time for me to quench it.
Woo hoo!
My clench went well.
The head of the sodegarami
looks pretty good.
I'm feeling pretty good
after getting to spend
this time on the weapon.
I'm excited to see
that I could do it,
and I'm excited for my daughter
and my scouts to see too.
Done pretty much
everything I wanted to do.
I have time to do
one more thing--
stab.
Attack a pumpkin Yoink!
Oh no!
[gasps] Ah!
Oh [bleep].
I got to fix this.
Oh, no.
[bleep]
I spent a lot of
time on this weapon,
and I've broken this thing.
So I'm just going to run back
and put whatever kind of crappy
weld I can get on it.
If this doesn't
work, I'm screwed.
My name is Justin Harrington.
I'm from Clemons,
North Carolina.
I've had one eye since
I was 12 years old,
and I've had a lot
of people tell me
what I can and can't do
in my life, and I just--
I've never taken their advice.
I came on "Forged
in Fire" to show
other people with
physical limitations
that they're not limitations.
They can be strengths.
So, we're going
to do a 15 and 20.
We'll clean at first, and
then we'll move on to our 1084
and clean that up.
The next process
is going to be just
welding these bad boys together
and getting a billet together.
I cut the billet
into four pieces.
I'm going to forge these
out into the four spikes
in the front of the sodegarami.
[chuckles] It's time to quench.
Go ahead and harden
just the blade,
leave the rest off so
that when they smack it
into whatever they're going
to smack it in, hopefully
it won't break.
A little Mongolian horsehair.
That is a blood guard.
Putting the head
in, and it seems
like it wanted to split on me.
So we're going to throw a
little bit of epoxy and leather
around this thing and
call it what it is.
If something goes
wrong with my weapon,
It's going to be that I
wasn't able to pin the head.
Just didn't have
the time to do it.
Hopefully, it stays together.
Sodegarami build is done.
She might not be pretty,
but she will kill.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the kill test.
To find out what kind of lethal
damage your sodegarami will do,
I will take your
weapons and stab
and try to snag this
ballistics dummy.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
[japanese]
All, right let's do this
[laughs]
All right, Rita.
Let's talk about
your sodegarami.
The tines you have
here penetrates.
The hook you have here
will rip this person apart.
And more importantly,
your weapon will kill.
Yes!
All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You read to have fun?
Yes, sir.
All right, Justin.
The tines you have here,
it's more of a stabbing tine
rather than a grabbing.
And this is a grabbing weapon.
But that hook does
grab on to that.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
All right, bladesmiths.
It's time for the
strength test--
the dreaded ice block chop.
Remember, this is not
about what these weapons
do to the ice blocks
but what those ice
blocks do to your weapons.
And Rita, you're up first.
You get points for
theme, I mean--
[laughs] you ready?
- A-ha.
- It doesn't matter.
Right.
No, it doesn't matter.
All right, Rita.
You got a little bit more of
a bend in this one tine here.
But everything else is pretty
much the way it was going in.
Definitely held up, did its job.
Good job.
- Thank you.
- All right, Justin.
Your turn.
You ready?
Yes, I am.
All right, so, you
survived the strength test.
This is a very strong,
well-built head for this.
But it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching.
I mean, I'm not sure
how effective it would
be at snagging the opponent.
But it's a devastator.
It certainly did the job.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths.
Welcome to the sharpness test--
the sandman pierce and capture.
To test the sharpness,
I will take your weapon,
pierce, and try to
control this sandman.
Rita, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
All right, Rita.
The points you have
on your tines here
definitely penetrate when
you thrust into that.
But it doesn't
slice on the way out
or capture as well as it should.
Your hook over here did its job.
Overall, it will
cut and control.
All right, Justin your turn.
Are you ready?
Yes, I am.
Oh ho ho.
That's not good.
He pulled it
out of the socket.
Well, Justin,
we have a problem.
Yes, sir.
This wasn't pinned, was it?
No.
The impact from all
these tests loosened it up.
And of course, it came off.
Justin, you brought in a
beautifully crafted weapon.
However, you've suffered
a catastrophic failure
in our final test.
And unfortunately, you cannot be
our "Forged in Fire" champion.
- Congratulations, Rita.
- Thank you.
Awesome.
Coming on "Forged in Fire,"
I put my all into it,
and I feel like I
made a good weapon.
But just came up
short on a little bit
of the fit and finish, and other
than that, I'm happy with it.
Rita, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
How do you feel right now?
I just--
Come on forward
and shake our hands.
Good job.
It's been a very
positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do
something amazing like this.
Thank you, you guys.
Oh my god.